Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Hace un tiempo estaba en un bar.
En otra mesa había una mujer
con su hijo de unos cinco años.
Ella estaba completamente
capturada por su celular.
Y mientras el nene la miraba.
Tal vez otro chico hubiera hecho lío
para tratar de llamar su atención.
Pero este nene no.
Esperó un buen rato,
finalmente se paró de su silla,
fue detrás de su mamá
y empezó a acariciarle el pelo.
Intentó convocarla con caricias
durante varios minutos.
Y ella en ningún momento se dio cuenta
de lo que estaba pasando.
Me invadió la pregunta:
¿cuántas veces habría estado yo
en la misma situación
sin siquiera darme cuenta?
¿Qué nos está pasando?
¿Por qué vivimos obsesionados
por nuestras pantallas?
Hoy desbloqueamos el celular
150 veces al día.
Esto es una vez cada 6 minutos durante
el tiempo que pasamos despiertos.
Decidí investigar sobre el tema
y llegué a una conclusión que me impactó.
Lo que nos está pasando con la tecnología
no es casualidad.
La Universidad de Stanford está ubicada
en el corazón de Silicon Valley,
la cuna de las mayores
compañías tecnológicas del mundo.
Ahí tiene su sede el Laboratorio
de Tecnología Persuasiva,
donde investigadores brillantes trabajan,
de acuerdo a sus propias palabras,
para ver cómo usar las páginas web
y las aplicaciones móviles que utilizamos
para manipular lo que pensamos
y lo que hacemos.
Intentar persuadir a los demás
es tan viejo como el mundo.
Pero los dispositivos digitales y
el enorme volumen de información personal
acumulado acerca de nosotros
a partir de nuestra actividad online
están creando una vía nueva de manipular
nuestros pensamientos y acciones
aprovechando las vulnerabilidades
de la mente
detectadas por la economía
del comportamiento,
la psicología y la neurociencia.
Los ejemplos abundan.
En la escala social,
los intentos por manipular elecciones,
la proliferación de noticias falsas,
el agrandamiento de todas las grietas.
En la órbita personal,
padres que no vemos a nuestros hijos
y, al revés,
reuniones donde cada uno
está más preocupado
por lo que pasa en su pantalla
que por lo que pasa a su alrededor.
Una dificultad cada vez más grande
para concentrarnos.
Este fenómeno empezó
con la expectativa inicial
de que todo en Internet
tenía que ser gratuito.
Un grupo de compañías tuvo
que encontrar la manera
de ganar dinero
sin cobrarle a los usuarios.
Lo primero que hicieron
fue poner publicidad
y empezar a cobrarle a los anunciantes.
Después vino empezar a recopilar
este montón de datos personales
para ultra-segmentar el mensaje
que nos dan a cada uno.
Finalmente, para aumentar sus ganancias
cada compañía necesitó que pasáramos
más y más tiempo en su plataforma.
Así nació el hackeo de nuestra atención.
Cuando el producto que
las empresas venden es tu atención,
todos compiten contra todos.
Facebook compite contra
otra red social como Twitter,
pero también compite
con productos muy diferentes
como YouTube, Netfilx o Fortnite.
Cada segundo que no estás ahí hipnotizado
es tiempo que ellos
no pueden vender a sus anunciantes.
Por eso utilizan notificaciones
visuales y sonoras
y todo tipo de trucos para distraerte
de cualquier cosa que estés haciendo,
inclusive cuando estás
usando las demás plataformas.
El primer presidente de Facebook
se convirtió hace un tiempo
en un arrepentido.
En una presentación contó
que él y Mark Zuckerberg
eran absolutamente conscientes
al desarrollar la plataforma
de estar explotando
vulnerabilidades de nuestra mente
para maximizar el efecto adictivo.
Pero él no fue el único en reconocer
el uso de estos mecanismos abusivos.
Recientemente el fundador de Netfilx
declaró que su mayor enemigo es el sueño.
Su meta es que durmamos menos para
que pasemos más tiempo mirando series.
Vendernos productos que
no nos hacen bien tampoco es nuevo.
Pero al menos los ejecutivos
de compañías como las tabacaleras
actuaban a la defensiva.
El fundador de Netflix no tiene reparos
en decirnos de frente que su compañía
está dispuesta a inducirnos hábitos
totalmente contrarios a nuestra salud
con tal de ganar más plata.
Para alcanzar estos fines
necesitan de nuestra ingenuidad.
Cuando vamos a comprar un producto,
digamos un par de zapatos,
tenemos cierta desconfianza.
Nos preguntamos cosas como ¿serán cómodos?
¿Tendrán buena calidad?
¿Estaré pagando un precio razonable?
Pero cuando el producto es gratis,
bajamos la guardia.
Si el producto es gratis tendríamos
que desconfiar mucho más todavía.
¿Por qué querría
una gran empresa multinacional
incurrir en los enormes costos
de desarrollar una red social,
una plataforma de videos,
un sistema de correo electrónico,
para que lo usemos gratis?
Nada es gratis en el mundo
de las empresas.
Si no estamos pagando con dinero,
¿de qué otra manera estaremos pagando?
Un área de manipulación
especialmente sensible es la autoestima.
El creciente uso de fotos y videos
como lenguaje principal en las redes,
le da una importancia absurda,
desproporcionada,
al aspecto estético y el aspecto físico
por sobre todas las demás
dimensiones de nuestra persona
frente a los ojos de los demás
y, por lo tanto, de nosotros mismos.
Y las redes aprovechan.
Las redes aprovechan
la fascinación que nos causa
espiar las vidas ajenas
e impactar a los demás
con nuestra propia imagen para
mantenernos indefinidamente cautivados.
Más aún, dado que cada uno de nosotros
comparte contenido muy poco espontáneo
de los momentos
más destacados de nuestro día
y convenientemente editado para
que parezcan mucho mejor de lo que fue,
cuando después vamos en
el colectivo, apretados, aburridos,
mirando una red social, resulta inevitable
que tengamos la errónea sensación
de que somos los únicos
que tenemos una vida común
más llena de obligaciones y percances
que de risas y puestas de sol.
Es inevitable que la comparación
contra estos falsos ideales
nos deje desilusionados
respecto de nuestra propia vida.
La decisión de a quién seguimos
y qué mostramos
es clave para romper los efectos
de este espejo distorsionado.
Si bien siempre fue cierto
que había personas más populares
y otros más retraídos,
de alguna manera esto está implícito.
Hoy se mide y está a la vista de todos.
Los me gusta y la cantidad de seguidores
son la moneda en la que hoy
se comercia la aceptación social.
Y cada acto queda sujeto
a la cuantificación pública
de la cantidad de me gusta que recibe.
Como resultado, empezamos a vivir la vida
para mostrarla, no para disfrutarla.
Ese es el pantano narcisista
en el que las redes nos metieron
y del que, curiosamente,
no queremos salir.
El deseo de encontrar a alguien
a quien amar y ser amados
nos deja en una posición
especialmente vulnerable.
El mes pasado la Secretaría de
Defensa del Consumidor de EE.UU.
demandó a la mayor
empresa mundial de citas.
Los acusa de aprovecharse
de la desesperación
de quienes no están pudiendo
encontrar pareja
para permitir que sean contactados
desde perfiles falsos,
invitarlos a pagar para entrar en contacto
con estas personas inexistentes
que después jamás devolverán sus mensajes.
¿Realmente vale todo
para retenernos como usuarios
y quedarse con nuestro dinero?
Otro grupo especialmente atractivo
y que resulta un blanco fácil
son nuestros chicos.
Es la adolescencia el momento
donde la manipulación de la autoestima
encuentra el terreno más fértil.
Pero el problema empieza
mucho antes que eso.
Los bebés también han sido descubiertos
como un nuevo target consumidor.
YouTube está lleno de videos
específicamente diseñados
para cautivarlos.
A pesar de que la recomendación
de la Organización Mundial de la Salud
es que los menores de dos años
no pasen ni un segundo frente a pantallas
la realidad es bien diferente.
El promedio de tiempo hoy
para chicos de dos años
es de dos horas y media al día.
Y un tercio de los bebés utiliza
pantallas desde antes de caminar.
En esta etapa crucial
del desarrollo del sistema nervioso
y de la psiquis, el chupete electrónico
se está convirtiendo en un tentador escape
para los padres y está reemplazando
al contacto físico,
el uso de la palabra
y los juegos de crianza.
Muchos padres incluso se enorgullecen
de la habilidad de sus bebés
para manejar los dispositivos.
Ven lo que sus hijos aprenden con
estos videos, los animales, los colores,
pero no ven los aprendizajes
y experiencias que se pierden.
Varios estudios científicos
están empezando
ya a mostrar las consecuencias negativas
de este cambio en áreas
como la adquisición del lenguaje,
el tiempo de atención
y el desarrollo socio-emocional.
El riesgo más grande para nuestros chicos
no es el uso temprano de pantallas
sino el corrimiento
excesivo de los adultos.
(Aplausos)
Frente a esto hay algunas personas
que dicen:
"Después de todo, es lo mismo de siempre.
En los 40 el villano era la radio,
en los 60 era la televisión,
en los 80 los videojuegos,
y ahora es esto".
Para Sócrates,
el villano era la escritura.
Siempre hay algo que los mayores
demonizan simplemente porque es nuevo.
Pero esta vez es distinto.
Porque si bien por inercia
seguimos llamando teléfono celular
a la supercomputadora ultraliviana
que cada uno lleva consigo,
este aparato es todo.
Es sí un celular pero
es también una cámara de fotos,
un televisor, un GPS, una consola
de juegos, una filmadora,
un navegador de Internet,
una linterna, un reloj despertador,
una calculadora, un equipo de música...
y muchas cosas más.
No solo es todo.
Está con nosotros en todo lugar
y en todo momento,
ofreciendo la promesa
de un flujo ilimitado de contenido
capaz de llenar el vacío
de cada instante de nuestra vida.
Y sin embargo, en esta era
de hipercomunicación
los estudios muestran que la cantidad
de gente que se siente sola
jamás fue tan alta como ahora.
No hay peor soledad que
la soledad rodeado de gente.
Y todo esto se va a poner peor.
Hasta ahora solo un puñado
de compañías aplicaba estos mecanismos.
Pero nuevos emprendimientos
están desarrollando software
para llevar estos métodos manipulativos
a todos los productos digitales.
El uso de la manipulación
y el hackeo de nuestra atención
recién están comenzando.
¿Qué hacemos entonces?
¿Abandonamos los celulares
y damos de baja las redes sociales?
No, no hace falta llegar a tanto.
Las ventajas de la vida conectada
son demasiado grandes
como para renunciar a ellas.
Pero estamos en una lucha desigual
entre compañías muy sofisticadas
y usuarios que actuamos con ingenuidad.
Firmamos un contrato escrito
por la otra parte sin siquiera poder leer
ni saber qué diablos estamos firmando.
Para nivelar la cancha
necesitamos entender cómo funcionan
estos mecanismos para poder
defendernos de la manipulación.
Si nos preguntamos cómo cada una
de estas compañías gana dinero
resulta más fácil tratar de
imaginar qué tipo de conductas
pueden querer estar induciendo en nosotros
y qué tipo de información
pueden estar procurando para hacerlo.
Por ejemplo, la próxima vez
que uses una aplicación de citas
tené presente que el negocio
de estas compañías
es que busques, no que encuentres.
Los dispositivos y las redes
nos mantienen ensimismados,
distraídos, impacientes
y enfocados en el consumo pasivo.
Pero no tiene por qué ser así.
Es momento de abandonar la ingenuidad
y lanzar la contraofensiva.
Podemos recuperar
el control de nuestra vida
para aprovechar los beneficios de la
tecnología sin quedar atrapados en ella;
aprovechar la supercomputadora
que llevamos con nosotros para crear,
no solo para consumir.
Usarla para vivir experiencias compartidas
en vez de quedar cada uno
encerrado en su propia pantalla.
En definitiva, el desafío es poner
las plataformas y los dispositivos
al servicio de la vida que queremos vivir,
no de la vida que otros
necesitan que vivamos.
(Aplausos)